it's hard to pay the bills when you
don't know when the next phone call will
come to offer you work whether it's
delivering pizza on a bike or driving a
stranger to the airport the Internet has
created new a typical forms of
employment the European Parliament is
calling for a strong legal framework
that will bolster and strengthen labor
rights in the changing digital economy
from our viewpoint this is a case where
we do need your pin loss because
otherwise we'll have workers competing
against workers and companies competing
against companies between different
medicines the European pillar of social
rights is meant to tackle long-term
social challenges for a generation of
young Europeans they have never been
better educated and yet they face a far
more precarious job market than their
parents or grandparents job has changed
in general whereas before hand you had a
full-time contract and you work from
nine to five it is no longer the case
working hours has changed work-life
balance is a very right question to be
asked and this is this is change as well
among the objectives of the Parliament
is to update existing social protection
measures like ensuring equal pay between
men and women and coordinating health
systems across Europe to make sure no
one is excluded from Social Security
still in the works the pillar may be an
effective tool to counter anti-eu
sentiment mbps have set an ambitious
wish list it's now up to the Commission
to deliver
[Music]
you
[Music]